il était annoncé dès le mois de février
2018 un commissariat au coeur de
planoise pour tenter d'apporter une
réponse adaptée à l'augmentation de la
violence dans le quartier
c'était le voeu du maire jean louis
fousseret un souhait qu'il avait
formulées dès les premiers jours de
l'installation place beauvau de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
difficile et donc qu'il faut prendre en
compte cette diversité
ce sera entre kas et 30 policiers
supplémentaires qui seront affectés ici
à besançon pour faire en sorte que comme
le maire dont sont aujourd'hui le
quartier de planoise ne sort pas un
quartier de non-droit plus d'effectifs
et l'aménagement d'un bureau de police
où la place cassin un plan d'action
contre la délinquance mené de concert
entre la ville de besançon
et ce grand projet du gouvernement dit
de reconquête républicaine dans les
quartiers difficiles
une mesure qui concernait plusieurs
dizaines de villes en france et dont la
capitale comtoise a donc bénéficié une
présence policière permanente à planoise
qui devrait au moins rassurer les 20000
habitants du quartier